hey guys Avengers infinity war first
walk well no more talking ah before
creation itself that was 16 July Wars
into Infinity stones
[Music]
this is our first day here we are fine
wood in Atlanta and it it's actually
pretty online of what promises to be a
year of fun-filled lensing I was never
actually going to see the first Avengers
with one of my best mates from home and
I've never dreamed that I'd ever be in
one of these movies let alone playing
spider-man I feel like I'm on top of the
world because this is just mind-blowing
what we always try to do with Marvel
Studios is we're building the cinematic
universe is look at the big picture how
can things relate across movies and
across the years Avengers infinity war
is the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe as started in May of
2008 at least environment 1 Wow
and it really is an unprecedented
culmination of a series of film
interlinks together which is time has
never been done before and for us the
important thing is making it all come
together we know they're going to face
venom we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 how do you do that in a way
that is unexpected that hits the
Avengers against somebody who is more
powerful than anyone they face and yet
make them completely unprepared to face
it well tear them apart which is why we
did Civil War before infinity war and we
were conceiving and executing civil war
the end of that movie was very much a
setup for what these movies would be we
always had that sense of that
like brother telling and not document
see is the Avengers are basically inane
with nobody in it the world is
vulnerable
Tony senses it's greater threats
approaching and so he is doing
everything in his power to keep your
face
Bannos shows us why he's the biggest the
best the baddest villain that we've ever
had and the most frightening villain of
the avengers have ever faced the most
exciting part is the incredible roster
of well developed characters and it's
going to create a really combustible
exciting massive scale adventure you
know that we're onto something within
the studio when we hit upon an idea or
we see a piece of concept art and all of
us in the room go physical and an
Avengers community war
The Avengers will need the guardians of
the Galvan
because of what Marvel is because of
what they have done over the last ten
years
these next two Avengers films will be in
a gently under they were seen on film
before
I'm excited that's pretty cool
I'm really excited I feel like the guys
at Marvel know what they're doing
I feel like now yeah I feel that now
more than ever especially with the last
wave of films we got like yeah I feel
like they finally hit their stride and
they know what they're going for and
they're going off in a lot of different
confident directions they get better I
think each time if anyone seen Civil War
I didn't look at it as an Avengers
Infinity Ward set up yeah I thought it
was just a great film yeah I did too and
with seeing how like it was very much
like they were going to do Civil War
specifically as a prelude to infinity
war makes more sense now like I always
thought that but then like hearing them
confirm that was like oh yeah it makes a
lot more sense because you got to bring
them back together and just honestly the
most exciting part of this whole footage
was just seeing Tony Stark and Chris
Pratt yeah I'm all in just chit-chatting
it's like you guys all hang around you
knowing the Guardians are good because
the guard is you know starting to the
galaxy where the one two are like often
another universe so seeing them all come
together it just in that frame and then
talking to the camera was like oh my god
this is legit happening this is crazy I
mean firstly at first Avengers mashup
was already nuts yeah how we're kind of
used to the mashaa
but this mashup has got to mean actually
genuinely excited specifically cuz are
like for sure including guardians of the
galaxy you know I don't know how that's
going to work and it's crossed over to
the point where I'm just excited to see
how they make it work because I'm pretty
confident as they can because you know
earlier on when they're like yeah we're
going to bring in guardians of galaxy in
the main MCU Oh like they feel like
they're from a different timeline but
like this stuff is is exciting to me is
when they're like oh yeah we're gonna
get more of these characters that we
love together and we're gonna bend
genres again and it seems like they're
asking themselves the right questions ya
know like yeah we've been setting up
Fanus for so long how do we really make
this feel unexpected
how do we how do we make this feel like
a major obstacle they have to work
together to overcome because it was all
just setup you're kind of just imagining
it's a big action film yeah but they're
really going out of the way to ask
themselves how can we still surprise the
audience because they're expecting the
unexpected but how do we give them the
unexpected when they're expecting to
happen you know and it seems like
they're asking the right questions and
they're sitting down and really thinking
it out they're not just going to go
cliche with it that's what I admire
about them the most I think is like they
really do seem eager to make these good
like that something is I really feel
like they care about the quality of
their franchise and the quality of their
movies and even when they don't always
hit that mark I always feel like that is
an intent here I feel like they're
really responsible and it does seem like
they're really willing to to learn and
to make each one you know better like
they take the quality their films really
seriously and I do it ain't like it's
interesting to look at them because it
is something new it's like this is the
first time where I've looked at like a
sort of hive mind that sort of authors
these movies and thought yeah you do
kind of have to have a group of people
together to manage the creative vision
of something exist that has so many
moving parts and so many different
series and it's got to crash characters
into it together it's exciting because
they're standalone films are really good
too they've gotten good at dialing it
back a little bit on you know crossover
stuff like teething chronic aggressive
or like a [ __ ] ton of people but but
even though even then it feels like more
than just crossover you know candy it
feels like it's necessary it feels
essential whenever they do that one that
even goes back to what the Russo
brothers said like wanting to honest
trailer proof it like it really seems
like they pay attention to that stuff
and they make tweaks every time and I
thought you know the most recent wave of
Marvel films I think was one of the
stronger ones are the more distinct yeah
ones to me so this is so cozy Robert
Downey and Tom Halloween Chris Pratt sat
next to each other yeah yeah like like I
don't always get excited for this stuff
but like this was cool like yeah I felt
like I was watching one like Pixar
making eyes
we're going to talk just about how much
we love this again yeah I'm excited
green screens and cool sets and [ __ ]
let's do it all right guys well thanks
for saying that our way you can
subscribe to the real rejects reading to
Gerry on Twitter and
I am social media manager of Facebook of
bloom house and the real rejects shout
out to DC you guys are just as good you
guys love money you guys are doing all
the right thing
yeah you don't have to learn anything
from Marvel you guys are on the right
path hick marketing though really top
notch trailer marketing right in those
controversies every time you step on
something